[Music]
hey everyone i'm stephanie wong a
developer advocate at google cloud
look tech has long been an industry
where women are underrepresented
but the good news is that's finally
changing with cloud today i am going to
talk about getting your first cloud job
as a woman in tech
while there are fewer women than men
getting computer science degrees it
doesn't mean there are fewer women
trying to break into cloud i myself
didn't graduate with a cs degree i
graduated with a different kind of cs
degree communication studies but my
minor introduced me to tech and i fell
in love
luckily with cloud came a culture shift
the cloud world is collaborative and
flexible the core foundations that have
become synonymous with cloud like the
cloud native computing foundation
are predicated on a culture of knowledge
sharing diverse perspectives and open
source contributions as a woman in tech
use your unique voice skills and
influence to blaze a path in cloud so
let's dive into key strategies to get
your first job let me just first say
that these strategies apply to anyone
trying to get a job in cloud but i want
to frame this for women as we might
experience added obstacles because we
don't see or know many other women in
the industry first don't let myths stall
your career
as you embark on your cloud journey
remember that it's often companies that
fail to retain great women not women who
fail to cut it at great companies
for example there is a myth that the
cloud world is driven by men with cs
degrees while we still have a lot of
work to do to close the gender gap in
tech the cloud computing space is
challenging the narrative because cloud
is relatively new technology there are
more opportunities and the landscape is
actually more diverse with a range of
personalities
just look at melody mcfessel a former vp
of engineering at google cloud or aperna
sinha director of product management at
google cloud the list goes on
if you have an interest in cloud learn
collaborate and just go for it focus on
a specialization there's a long-standing
debate whether you should go deep in one
area or abroad when it comes to cloud
because there are endless areas to learn
about infrastructure security
microservices networking api management
and more but becoming a leader in the
every evolving cloud market is all about
specialization visibility and experience
because the cloud industry is so vast
deference is given to the thought
leaders of their respective fields
but don't let it hinder your start in
cloud when i first started in tech i
consumed up everything i could about the
cloud and how each piece fit together
vms databases networking and developer
tooling
i enjoy seeing the big picture and as
such i consider myself a cloud
generalist knowing a little bit about
everything while still being able to go
deeper in certain areas like networking
i then mastered the art of presenting a
range of cloud topics across mediums
like videos podcasts and talks i guess
you could say i specialized in becoming
a generalist distilling complex topics
and educating through online content so
don't feel like specialization means
that you need to color inside the lines
number three build a support system
with a shortage of women representation
self-doubt can swoop in
you need to find and create a system of
people who have traveled the same
journey you're navigating there are so
many organizations and networks created
for women to come together to help women
get jobs in cloud learn and network some
of my favorites include
women techmakers anitab.org built by
girls women in cloud and your school or
company cloud women's groups and if you
don't have one consider starting one
and check out other cloud forums like
google cloud innovators a cloud guru and
hundreds of meetups around the world on
meetup.com networking does sound cliche
but it's really about building
relationships and finding people who can
become your biggest champions
and that leads me to number four find a
good mentor
i first-handedly know how powerful a
mentor can be
not only have i had incredible mentors
throughout my career but in 2020 i met
one of my mentees through the ucla
mentorship program she also had a ba in
communication studies and wanted to find
someone in a technical role who had a
different background like herself so it
was a perfect match
but it was also very hard in 2020 for
her to find a job during the pandemic
i helped coach her and showed her
resources lesser-known boot camps and
introduced her to my network until she
was able to secure a job in the tech
industry
so find a mentor program through your
own networks or organizations like anita
b
you can also use social media to meet
cloud professionals
but before you ask them to be your
mentor remember that finding a good
mentor can't be transactional i recently
interviewed a leader at google and she
described it as building your own board
of advisors where each person is
invested in your future
for them to be invested they need to
care about you and that takes
relationship building
find areas of overlap and take the time
to nurture that relationship offer your
skills so they see your potential and
want to see you succeed
number five don't let self-doubt get in
the way
it can be scary to work in an industry
where you may be the only woman in the
room or on a project and you might
question if you even belong there
many of us believe that there tends to
be little room for error for women we
might get penalized for making small
mistakes
and this can lead to us walking on
eggshells or over analyzing our
qualifications for a role and that
gut-wrenching feeling of imposter
syndrome
when i landed my first cloud job i had
to learn everything on the job when i
joined google i even felt more imposter
syndrome comparing myself to the
engineers around me
but
each time i made big moves into cloud
computing i realized after 12 months my
self-doubt would subside and my
confidence grew as i gained more
experience
so do not let self-doubt get in the way
of picking up new concepts and having a
voracious appetite to learn it just
might take a little bit of time so be
patient
number six stay authentic
if there's anything that i learned along
my journey it's that staying true to
myself and my interests outside of work
will lead to better job fit and
happiness later on i was never shy about
my dance or pageant background and in
fact those are the things that helped me
excel in cloud because they gave me the
confidence to present and tell stories
then i was able to land on a role that
let me hone both my technical and my
communication skills
which is why you're watching me in this
video today
so never let the stereotypes of the tech
industry sway your career choices
whether it's coincidental or not the
rise of cloud was accompanied by a
significant drive to recognize and
support women in cloud
the culture of the cloud industry is
very welcoming and cloud as a technology
is often credited as democratizing the
resources needed for women to take their
place as professionals and entrepreneurs
so in summary don't let myths stall your
career
focus on a specialization
build a support system
find a good mentor
don't let self-doubt get in the way and
stay authentic best of luck in your own
journey like and subscribe to our
channel we will be back with more advice
on how you can crack your cloud career
[Music]
food
[Music]